-I think for people our age,
your memory of this impeachment
saga is far different.
Like, you think about it,
or I think about it
when I reflect back on it,
as a political event.
And this show does
a very nice job
of showing how
human beings were affected,
and in particular, how young
Monica Lewinsky was
when this was all happening.
-Monica Lewinsky --
I mean, there are so many things
about Monica's experience
during this time
that I had no idea about.
And I, too, had my own opinions
about Monica.
But, you know, she was held
in a hotel room by the FBI
for 12 hours while waiting
for her mother to come
from New York City to D.C.,
and, you know, it just --
When you really, really
think about it,
she was essentially a child.
And there was one person who
should have been responsible
to not only his family,
but to the country,
and that didn't happen so much.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-You know who I'm talking about.
-I do know who.
-Okay. Cool, cool.
I'm sort of a political junkie.
-Are you? Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I want to also --
you talk about responsibility.
And you also, not just as an
actor but as a producer on this,
you guys obviously understood
you had a responsibility
as well.
And I know Monica worked on it.
-She did.
-But, you know, there were
other people involved.
And, you know, Linda Tripp
is someone that I think
we all just have this one idea
of who she is.
-Yeah. Detestable traitor.
Betrayer of a friend. Yeah.
-And you wanted to make sure
you got this right.
No to sort of sugar-coat
her behavior,
but just to try to present
a more three-dimensional person.
-Yeah, because I feel like,
why do it otherwise?
John Goodman already did
an excellent job
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Very three-dimensional.
-Very three-dimensional,
showed all the aspects of it.
I really didn't know
where to go from there.
It felt like a complete thing.
So, I just...
The thing is,
Linda was a wonderful mother
and subsequently
a wonderful grandmother
and had a lot of attributes
as a human being
that were worthwhile in terms of
the human experience.
But she did do, I think,
an unforgivable,
very, to this day, to me,
still mysterious thing.
I've tried to come up with the
reasons why I think it happened.
I -- I have the reason.
I let the rest of the world
determine
whether or not they think
that suffices.
But, you know, I was terribly
sad when she died.
-She passed away last year.
-She died in April 2020.
We were supposed to start
shooting in March,
and then of course,
because of the pandemic,
we didn't start shooting
till October of 2020,
instead of March.
And, you know, I got so many
texts the day she died,
as if it were me or somebody
that I actually knew.
-Was she aware that you guys
were embarking on it?
-I have no idea.
I had a fantasy of being able
to meet her one day
and just tell her
that I had a lot of --
I wouldn't say sympathy,
but empathy
for what she went through.
-Well, I think, yeah,
what you said really rings true,
and I think it's a thing
that people talk about now,
which is you can do
a terrible thing,
but there are the sort of
multitudes of every human being.
-Correct.
And, you know, I do believe
deep down she thought
she was doing something
for a greater good.
It's just probably greatly
blinded by other factors,
and didn't think about
the consequences on this,
as we were saying,
terribly, terribly young woman.
-You did hear -- you got
feedback from I think it was --
we were talking backstage --
one of her daughters.
-Yeah, Allison,
who is featured in the show
quite heavily as we go along.
There does come a point
in the story
where Monica and Linda are
no longer together,
where they basically
never saw each other again,
so that happens.
I was very moved by what I read
that her daughter said.
And for me,
as far as critics go,
it's the only thing
that mattered to me
that she in fact -- at least as
far as seeing the first episode.
She made it very clear
where she was like,
"I've only seen one
and I may not hold on to this
thought by the end of it,"
which is totally fair.
But it meant that maybe,
you know --
she sort of said she wished
her mother could have seen it,
and that to me is...
single tear.
-Yeah, single tear.
You mentioned your getting
your lightning bolt --
electrified hair.
-Yes.
-And then you've been out
with it, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's Hypodermic Sally,
and it's not even the most
effective photograph.
-This one kind of looks fine.
-This one looks fine.
-But there is one --
-If you were like --
You guys know Hypodermic Sally.
You're like,
"Yeah, she's pretty hot."
Well, I want you
to meet her friend.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I mean, really.
It's almost as if Ryan doesn't
like me very much.
Isn't this what it seems like?
-So, you have, you've been out
in, like, public.
-I would shoot until, you know,
11:00 at night
and forget that
I looked like this,
'cause I was also shooting
Marcia Clark at the same time,
which was another really stellar
physical -- a lot of wigs.
But this was my own hair.
This is not a wig, Seth.
-This is the real thing?
-This is my hair.
I would walk at night
to the supermarket, as you do,
and I would get my items and
I would go to pay for them,
and the gentleman behind
the counter was always like,
"I'll -- I'll take your..."
Like, here's a quarter and
a nickel and he's like,
"Oh, just take it.
Just take it."
'Cause it was not...
I had scratches painted on me.
It was bad.
-How many times -- do you know
off the top of your head
how many times
you've worked with Ryan?
-Do I count each iteration
of "American Horror Story"?
-You do.
-Individually?
-Yeah.
-So, that's nine seasons of
"American Horror Story,"
two seasons of "Crime Story.
I did a pilot for him
called "Nip/Tuck."
I did...
What else did I do?
Oh, I did "Ratched."
-Yeah.
-"Pretty/Handsome"
was the pilot I did.
"Nip/Tuck" I did an episode of.
So, that's...
-Yeah, that's --
-"Feud," I was in.
Did anybody count?
Was anybody counting?
-I think it's like 14 or 15,
but I think it's impressive.
-Were you really counting?
-I was, like...
I mean, there was like nine...
-You stopped at one point.
-You said nine, and then I was
just like, I'm just gonna add...
[ Laughter ]
-"You were like, "Night-night."
"Let me know when you're done
counting, Paulson."
-But it's a very
impressive number.
You guys must have a very nice
shorthand now, I would imagine.
-We do.
It goes like this.
"Hi. This is what you're doing."
"Great. Bye."
-And that's sort of it.
-Now off to the wigs!
-Off to the wigs, and I'll see
you later, and you know.
-It's always great to see you.
-Really good to see you, too.
-Congratulations on the show.
Thanks for being here in person.
-Thanks, man.
Thanks for having me.
-Next time I'll have
an audience for you.
-Please do.
-I will.
"Impeachment" airs Tuesdays
at 10 p.m. on FX.
"American Horror Story:
Double Feature"
airs Wednesdays
at 10 p.m. on FX.
and streaming the next day
via FX and Hulu --
You're everywhere, Sarah.
-I'm everywhere.